the famous restaurant which regrettably
closed the early on after I moved in
with luis and Sheridan square where for
a dollar seventy-five you could have the
best veal parmesan ever made in this
country and for a dime a glass of beer
the limelight was another restaurant
that had a prix fixe menu dollar
seventy-five three courses I entered the
village about the time that the village
voice became the leading non-regular
newspaper in the country I don't matter
how they refer to it dan wolf the editor
and adventure the publisher were friends
of mine and I'm very proud of the fact
that they endorsed me for every position
i ran for when i was when i ran for
assembly Congress district leader mayor
City Council I was their candidate and
I'm I never ever stop thanking them
or some whoever said that what was
interesting was that my greatest
strength was not with the Jews because
they didn't think I was liberal enough
you know you know everybody if you're
Italian your base is Italian if you're
Jewish your basis the Jewish if you're
black you're basis black and then you
build on that base for getting others
but my base was never Jewish my base is
Italian and Irish was so peculiar the
Jews when they took pose seventy-three
percent of them were for me this would
be for mayor eighty-one percent of the
Catholics Italian and Irish or for me
because i have always perceived myself
as a liberal with sanity I've never been
crazy and in fact many liberals would
say you're not liberal enough I say
listen I believe that what I am for
makes common sense and often what your
Ford there's not you can call it liberal
enough or not liberal enough I know what
it is that I want to see this country
Abby and apparently a majority of the
people who vote think of it the same way
as I do so I ain't changing
you